the finest population walk in chile
architect my foundation computer and
so that the person in charge of the area
scarce resources I think it has been a
very enriching fire has been muscle
where are we going have they put in the
main issues on the table one of
the questions that has to do with
maybe what is the most used resource
here in america and I agree with many
the analysts that I think the
people actions sites used as
resources I think we have to give a
important step
really realize what is important
that you have to invest people not
only in investing in trust
among people I think the only
way we have as america
of really can only do more
important forward
with many crises and many policies
important misunderstandings of
meaning there is a very important challenge
ahead of how we achieve when
connect companies the organization
civil society and communities
social entrepreneurs to be able